dans l'univers des caméras d'action il y
a vachement de choses il y a une nouveau
produit qui vient de sortir c'est insta
à 360 c'est la GO 3 elle est juste là
elle est planquée elle est toute petite
en plus de ça après on peut venir la
mettre là-dessus elle se positionne là
vous avez un écran qui bouge pour le
bloc c'est génial donc une caméra vous
allez pouvoir emmener partout avec vous
on se fait aujourd'hui un point complet
sur la GO 3 de insta360
la particularité de la GO 3 d'un stade
360 c'est bien c'est qu'elle est hyper
modulable ou en faire un petit peu ce
que vous voulez déjà vous commencez par
la mettre là alors là vous me direz ok
il y a un coup de magie c'est vrai il y
a de la magie c'est vrai je vous le
cache pas en fait elle est juste comme
ça et ce qui est génial c'est qu'on peut
venir la mettre comme ça après on peut
la mettre comme ça et vous aurez l'image
que vous voulez tout serai dans
l'application c'est extrêmement pratique
et ça ça marche avec quoi et bien ça
marche avec un petit pendentif en fait
qui est monté et que vous venez planquer
et que vous mettez là alors
effectivement comme ça c'est un peu
moins joli dessous c'est plus joli ici
en plus vous mettez un petit t-shirt
blanc et bien c'est extrêmement pratique
c'est donc une caméra compacte qu'on va
pouvoir avoir à la main et en fait c'est
deux modules différents vous avez votre
GO 3 cette petite partie centrale
convient retirer en appuyant sur le
bouton sur le côté vous appuyez dessus
vous la retirez elle parle en fait c'est
un support magnétique vous venez la
reposer c'est magnétique ça la Poste à
la clip c'est là elle peut plus bouger
le seul moyen qu'elle bouge c'est de
venir appuyer sur le bouton sur le côté
et là vous pouvez venir la retirer donc
là c'est la position numéro 1 position
numéro 2 hop là vous le prenez sur la
casquette vous venez le positionner là
s'il y a pas un accessoire en fait chez
un certain 360 ça qui est pratique vous
le mettez là vous prenez votre caméra et
vous venez la positionner en haut sur
votre tête et là deviendra filmer ce que
vous voyez donc là vous voyez je le vois
je le vois vous voyez vous voyez le
monsieur qui part vous voyez ça bref on
voit tout c'est très pratique
et bien votre caméra vous venez la
positionner là-dedans l'action pot sert
à accueillir la GO 3 lorsque vous l'avez
ici prenez la caméra et vous venez
directement la positionner ici à
l'intérieur c'est vanter elle arrive
directement et en plus d'avoir un petit
moniteur derrière que vous allez pouvoir
venir relever grâce à des petites
encoches sur le côté donc là vous voyez
directement avec votre caméra et vous
pouvez venir vous filmer comme ça donc
là je me vois je suis en train de me
balader alors petit vlog aujourd'hui on
est sur le GR20 on tombe vous voyez
parce qu'on est toujours en tombant sur
le Jerba quand on veut le faire
correctement avec son côté un bouton ON
OFF pour venir l'allumer pour l'éteindre
le bouton Q qui sert à accéder aux
paramètres et au réglages de l'autre
côté le petit bouton pour venir
effectivement libérer la GO 3 de la
recharge en usb-c un bouton pour lancer
l'enregistrement sur le dessus et sur le
dessous vous avez des attaches parce
qu'il y a pas mal d'accessoires pour
plus de ça j'ai plein de modes
différents là je suis en train de vous
montrer je suis en train de filmer en 4K
je crois c'est du 30 images par seconde
mais j'ai un autre qui est extrêmement
stabilisé tout ça en plus je peux venir
piloter avec mon application vous allez
voir ça juste top ici dans l'application
vous avez déjà un aperçu de ce que vous
êtes en train de filmer vous voyez j'ai
la caméra qui est là je vois je veux
venir changer les modes directement en
bas l'intervalle de photos le starlable
vidéo free Fame le Time la le timeshi le
ralenti l'enregistrement en boucle
également il y a plein d'options c'est
vachement bien ça pour tous les contenus
créatifs et vous choisissez votre
résolution ici vous voyez je suis en 2,7
4 images par seconde et en un clic
choisir tout ce que je veux ce qui est
cool c'est que vous voyez le temps je
suis en 169 je passe en 9 16 directement
donc ça c'est quand même super simple
j'ai que en un clip et bien je peux dire
m'adapter pour son des différents
réseaux sociaux sur lesquels je vais
pouvoir si j'ai pas envie de galérer
avec mes menus comme ça et bien jusqu'à
cliquer ici et je vais avoir des
raccourcis ça c'est aussi très très
pratique et puis ensuite je peux venir
cliquer là j'ai accès à tous mes
fichiers je vais venir modifier
directement ici dans mon application
c'est quand même vachement vachement
simple ensuite je demande album je vais
retrouver tous mes clips je vais pouvoir
ensuite les télécharger pour les éditer
et me faire un film très facilement j'ai
même de l'édition automatique je clique
là j'étais à sélectionner les éléments
qui m'intéressent ça ça et ça je fais
suivant lui il analyse il fait le taf
essayer de me trouver un rythme il va
m'ajouter des effets des transition il
vient de faire un montage tout seul donc
la rythme rapide 27 secondes et qui est
livré rythme plus lent moi j'aime bien
le rapide je me suis là il met de la
musique voyez j'ai mon rythme alors
après je peux venir il était modifier
des choses mais je trouve ça juste
topissime là je suis en 169 mais je peux
changer je peux le mettre en un par un
en carré tout simplement et après je
peux mettre également 9e fonction des
plans que j'ai shootés donc si j'ai
shooté à la verticale ou à l'horizontale
et bien j'aurais pas la même chose ici
et comme je peux venir modifier
directement après en post-production
c'est quand même vachement pratique donc
là c'est light vlog port Ravel et qui a
choisi ensuite on va se dire travel
voyage dans vlog my best friend je
clique dessus ça me l'applique donc j'ai
des petitesplay comme ça je trouve ça
vachement pratique je trouve ça
extrêmement malin donc une fois de plus
si vous voulez venir créer du contenu
sans vous embêter vous avez vachement
modularité avec cette caméra il y a un
autre qui est extrêmement pratique c'est
que comme je l'ai ici voyez en mode
puntoview c'est à dire que c'est ce que
vous voyez ce que moi je suis en train
de voir alors comme si décalage de
hauteur vous voyez sauf si jamais au
niveau de la tête au niveau de la
casquette mais je préfère encore des
moustiques je préfère le mettre là je me
prends des pommes de pin par la gueule
non mais tu le crois c'est toi qui les
jette c'est pas possible c'est toi qui
les jette ce qui est cool c'est que vous
voyez ce que je vois et en plus votre
point qui est vraiment vraiment cool et
bien c'est que lui je peux venir
l'utiliser comme un petit moniteur
externe lorsqu'elle est posée par
exemple ici et que moi je vais me
filmais donc là tu bouges pas magnifique
caméra ta stature et bien je l'ai le
retour juste ici je peux appuyer je vais
lancer l'enregistrement qui n'était pas
lancé donc là ça y est c'est parti on
voit qu'on a la petite diode qui permet
de savoir quand même parce que vous
filmez les gens ça c'est quand même la
moindre des choses et bien j'ai
l'enregistrement qui est là voilà et
comme ça je peux venir ensuite faire mon
petit truc coucou ça va je me vois en
même temps directement en face ici
[Musique]
ce qui est cool si vous pouvez filmer
jusqu'à 45 minutes avec votre GO 3 et si
vous rajoutez l'action pod vous montez
jusqu'à 173 minutes d'enregistrement en
1080p à 30 images par seconde et l'autre
truc qui est cool il faut le dire on est
quand même ici qu'elle est étanche
jusqu'à 5 mètres
vous pouvez aller sous l'eau avec la GO
3 et que par contre l'action pod lui une
certification IPX4 qui donne résistant
aux éclaboussures mais il est
certainement pas fait pour les sous
l'eau que je vous conseille lorsque vous
venez de remettre et que votre GO 3 a
pris la flotte et bien c'est de bien
venir la sécher avant de la mettre dans
l'action pod comme ça il y a pas de
mauvaise surprise prendre ma caméra en
mode vidéo free fine je vais tourner
tourner tourner tourner et ça va rester
droit tout le temps donc là je suis en
train de tourner ma carrière vous le
voyez sur le mur sur le petit bord je
tourne la caméra et rien ne tourne donc
le truc est vraiment juste génial ici
donc ça c'est vachement bien parce que
vous voulez venir faire de la vidéo
d'action lorsque vous voyez vous balader
par exemple lorsque vous êtes sur un
vélo lorsque vous faites en mode action
et bien ça ne bougera pas c'est du
maintien de l'horizon quelque sorte le
truc est vraiment vraiment top
vous appuyez sur le côté et après vous
avez un écran tactile qui vous permet de
vous guider très facilement vous
choisissez l'objectif Linéa action
ultra ultra c'est très grand et ultra
large vous voyez bien ma main comme ça
ici et si vous switchez en Linéa
forcément c'est un peu plus petit la
résolution également 2,7k 1440p 1080p il
sait également le nom d'image par
seconde le ratio 16/9/16 à vous de voir
la stabilisation Max au standard
désactivé pour moi c'est Max sur le côté
vous allez avoir les plans que vous avez
filmé en allant de l'autre côté vous
allez voir vos paramètres standard vide
bref comme vous voulez en fonction de ce
dont vous avez besoin vous pouvez le
faire en manuel en automatique je vous
recommande quand même automatique si
vous n'êtes pas un spécialiste et sur le
haut vous allez avoir vos différents
paramètres et quand vous appuyez sur le
bouton QI bien vous choisissez ensuite
ce que vous allez faire là je suis en
cycliste ski la nerf vlog starlapse ça
c'est pour les préréglages vous pouvez
venir en créer d'autres en appuyant ici
venir les personnaliser vous l'utilisez
comme ça avec l'écran vous vlogez vous
vous regardez vous la détachez vous
l'utilisez en Caméra d'Action vous
l'attacher sur
ça bouge plus c'est pratique puis vous
avez un protège objectif et en fait
planquer là il faut absolument mettre
lorsque vous allez sous l'eau parce que
si vous le mettez pas et bien ça risque
de poser problème et ce qui est cool
c'est que si vous venez le rayer par
exemple sur des cailloux et bien vous
pouvez venir le changer votre caméra
n'est pas du tout abîmée et puis lorsque
je suis en train de filmer j'ai quelques
informations au niveau de l'écran je
vois mon niveau de batterie qui me reste
le nombre d'heures qui me reste sur
l'enregistrement sur la carte et puis
surtout une fois de plus le fait d'avoir
ce petit moniteur pour venir se voir
vous le voyez pas mais moi je me vois je
trouve ça juste extraordinaire vous avez
trois configurations 32 Go de stockage à
429,99 € 64 Go de stockage à 449,99 € et
128 Go de stockage à 479 euros 99 vous
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez de cette
caméra d'action est-ce qu'elle peut vous
tenter oui non quoi comment puis le mode
vlog aussi une fois de plus et quand
même vachement cool très très canon et
hyper sexy donc dites-moi vous ce que
vous en pensez est-ce que cette Go 3
pourrait vous tenter si elle vous tente
bien évidemment et bien je vous mets le
lien juste en bas dans la description
pour aller la découvrir et voir un peu
plus d'informations sur le site d'insta
360 et puis surtout merci à insta360 de
m'avoir permis de la tester et de
sponsoriser cette vidéo voilà je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et à très
bientôt Ciao